the first thing fans will notice when
they arrive at stadium 974 is that it
looks a bit like it was constructed
using children's building blocks and
that's not entirely too far from the
truth just on a much bigger scale this
stadium has been put together with
974 shipping containers 40 000 seats and
a metal structure
the shipping containers in this stadium
not just there to provide decoration and
color many of them have functions we're
now down on the ground floor of the
stadium right next to the players tunnel
and as you can see this one is the
referee's dressing room so let's take a
look inside come on in and we'll have a
look at how it's been fitted out as you
can see there is a sink over there a
couple of toilets and there are also
some lockers just behind me where they
can put away their clothes
they call this a modular stadium it has
its advantages it keeps costs low it
lowers the number of building materials
they need to use and it can be put up
relatively quickly since this container
were fabricated fully and visited out in
china most of the steel elements were
fabricated in vietnam and turkey
once we had them on site it took us from
november 19 when we started replacing
the first
container and final position until
march 21 which is roughly a year and six
months
[Music]
[Applause]
after the tournament the roof the seats
the shipping containers and all the
metal frames will be taken apart and
sent overseas to other projects it's all
part of the idea of sustainability and
legacy for the middle east's first world
cup
since day one we thought of legacy which
is one of the most factors and
commitments that we had during the bid
back in 2010 and even with the concept
of having a temporary stadium i think
this would enhance even the sporting
industry
[Music]
using shipping containers is also a nod
to the stadium's location it's right
next to doha bay next to the old doha
port and it also has the best view of
the city skyline